it's my favorite part of the day
it's almost three o'clock which means
i'm almost gonna see my mikey dude
i
literally cannot wait to be with him all
the time as soon as i wake up i can't
wait to wake him up if he's not waking
us up first um or if he's at school i
can't wait to pick him up once he's done
with practice i can't wait to be with
him
this is wild like the amount
of love and enjoyment and joy that i
receive from just being
and and nurturing
and
just
seeing my little monkey dude exist
makes me so damn happy makes me feel so
damn fulfilled i could cry just thinking
about it so i won't i'll spare you the
tears but i'm super stoked
every time i get to um
get all his stuff together he has his
ghee
he won't let me forget
his little trunk litas his little slides
because when you do jiu-jitsu you're not
supposed to wear shoes on the mat and
because you're not supposed to wear
shoes on the mat they don't want you to
walk around off the mat without shoes so
you need to be wearing shoes that you
can slip in and out of very easily
and the point being is that's just the
way traditionally bjj was done
you use a ghee there are some schools
that and this is a ghee
there are some schools that use rash
guards which they look like long sleeve
or they could be short sleeve but
they're like this performance uh
material
um
and yeah you do it barefoot um
yeah you're not really supposed to walk
around and get your feet dirty and then
bring it back on the mat because you're
rolling around on it your face is
smashed on it like there's just so many
germs that can uh get on the mat if
you're just like
uh very dirty and um what's the word
unhygienic
um
and i always have to have this little
water because they always do a bunch of
drills and they run back and forth
and then they get these little you know
30 second water breaks so i have to make
sure i have all this oh and the last
thing he doesn't like the ghee material
because if you look at it let's put it
under the sun
it's this very thick
super coarse
material so wearing it against the skin
the inside is definite it's not made for
comfort that's for damn sure
um
he doesn't like the way it feels
so
i get his favorite shirts i'm surprised
that's not a mild shirt and then i get
um some shorts for him he wears that
underneath
he's a comfy boy
so
today's class starts an hour later
normally his class starts at four but
today starts at five i didn't get
hungry during lunch today i was just so
busy working and
um wrapping up the rest of the year for
barbell brigade
we have a lot of really cool apparel
launches coming up and supplement
launches with brand new flavors one of
them
uh two of them i should say well there's
a few of them but the two that i'm very
stoked on that are going to be released
in a couple weeks are our immunity
support
um
and that one's
so if you've gone to a mexican
restaurant you have that pineapple water
it's called alpina
boom so that's what we flavored it
uh as and then we have performance
greens
and that one
is like a cucumber
cucumber water but it's a cucumber limey
sweet um and i'm so stoked for you guys
to taste it ugh i'm so excited and then
we have like really dope protein flavors
coming out that i'm just so excited to
share but i'm just gonna wait i'm just
gonna wait a little bit um
so yeah that's what i was working on
so focused that like when i looked up
and i'm like oh [ __ ] so i'll just have
lunch or get a little snack with my
little monkey dude it'll be a mama and
me dates right now bart is shooting
um jk films it's being
jk news sorry it's being filmed out here
in vegas
cool concept
can't wait for you guys to watch it i
barely know the concept like i just know
a very rough outline of what the concept
is i haven't seen the final product i
don't know what the final product is
going to be like from what i hear it
changed a little bit
in a very funny way so stoked for you
guys to see that as well
a lot of stuff going on
i picked up my cuny duty what are we
doing cuny duty
yes so maybe like
one time
oh cool
maybe one time every few months or every
couple months
he loves mcdonald's because obviously
happy meal hello
there's been psychological studies done
and they know what they're doing to hook
these kids so young i'm one of those
kids for damn sure but anyway
um yeah so right now uh we're eating in
the car obviously but
we're just trying to pass time and i'm
also hungry um before his jiu jitsu
class huh monkey duty
what did you order
golden french fries all right those are
my favorite types too when they're super
golden
what's going on you okay yeah it's so
hot oh okay
okay so this is day two
check this out
we are unintentionally matching we got
the black the gray
you already see the black
so you already know what's going to
follow
the gray
we look ridiculous and we're a raiders
family can't help it hey
that's true
how many raiders have you gone to babe
name one of the players
how do you even play football there's a
taylor there's a tailor in there
probably
there's a smith yep at least this man
clearly we don't know jack baby there's
the baby for sure there's the baby on
the readers right
yes
you wanna be in there
it's over it's not over you keep going
so right now we are going to go to chuck
e cheese i was trying to prep taika
because before uh i turned the camera on
we were listening to sunflower and as
you guys know
uh youtube doesn't like when it hears
other music that doesn't belong to you
so we're always so scared so we don't
want the video to get taken down um so i
was turning i turned or i paused the
song i should say and tyga kept singing
it that's the clip that you guys saw but
uh right now we are on our way to where
are we going
have you been at chuck e cheese before
what do you think the inside's going to
be like
the cave yeah how do you know oh i don't
know what makes you think there's going
to be games oh but
pizza
because you have pizza they do have
pizza but how do you know there's going
to be games in there are you guessing
yeah oh okay
that's a big cuny guy time what whoo
what
wait why are your hands in your pockets
oh can you have the card i think really
yes
a little bit close hey monkey yeah so we
have some development on
taika being afraid of being blown away
you like that
like that
okay so what happened today so we went
to the park and did you fly away no no i
was trying to pretend yeah you were
trying to pretend yeah what did you do
were you holding mama and papa's hands
the whole time
no
no
yeah taiko is a big super
big so yeah there's an apron in this guy
a big super brave boy today um
he challenged himself and he says mama
and papa we were about like i don't know
like 100 yards away from the park at
this point and he's like mama papa uh
i don't want to hold your hand anymore
i'm going to be brave i want to walk i'm
not afraid of the wind anymore and you
could tell he was really scared because
prior to that he was going
as soon as he would feel wind on his
hair so he challenged himself and he
overcame his fear of flying away and you
were playing at the park all by yourself
and it got to the point that he just
started trolling himself he was like
whoa whoa whoa i'm gonna blow away whoa
and he kept like pretending he's gonna
go
down and then you fell down i haven't
made two tons
i'm so proud of you dude
you brave monkey monkey yeah
but what about tomatoes
okay that's a different story dude so i
was trying to tell him
how i'm like where did you see that
i was like where did you see that you're
gonna um fly away and he says youtube
and i said all right judy i'm like i'm
sorry but i can't let you watch so much
youtube he watches uh kid youtube i do
not allow him to watch regular youtube
because regular youtube is weird um
this time you can yes but let me explain
let me explain
let me explain what happened so i said
dude you can't watch youtube because
right now you think things that are
pretend are real and look at how scared
you are and he goes no but it is real i
saw on youtube a kid flew away and i'm
like monkey that doesn't happen so i was
telling him it's pretend
and then he saw on youtube again he goes
uh so i was finally convincing him and
then if like a week later he's like okay
mom you said that i can't fly away and
he goes what about tornados
and i was like
i was hoping he wouldn't bring that up
but
it's super strong they could blow
everything away yeah baby
chicken leg
books
oh my god what about houses and cars and
trees remember you said all that yeah i
liked where did you see it
on youtube oh
i never
yeah oh
yeah so yes tornadoes are scary and yes
they do
tear things up however
right there
um i'm like we don't get tornadoes here
in nevada or in california so we're safe
okay monkey yeah
okay what okay baby chicken leg
hey monkey say hi to chucky
where right there oh yeah i see him
did you say hi to him
oh that's a real one that's why
cuny guy
hey sit down no that's inappropriate you
don't do that thank you
there he is
he's actually probably a 17 year old
sticky sneaky guy
they're looking for a job
and he has to switch the outfit with
different people it was so cute because
earlier he's like i want to give chucky
cheese a hug so bad and i was like why
he's like because he's so cute and then
he hugs somebody goes why smell like
that
good job
[Music]
good job judy
yeah that's pretty good you're better
than me already
oh never mind
i suck at games
play
[Music]
yeah okay there we go
oh we gotta start shooting
oh my god crashed
already oh no i gotta shoot the bad guys
oh no
there they are
automatic weapons
now we have to get the world famous
chuck e cheese
and this one doesn't look like they're
putting it together remember there was
that like yeah
this looks like it's all one pizza take
a bite see if it's like the way we
remember
i don't remember where it was
good is it good it's pretty good
yummy pizza
we are going home now
no no no no
no we are going home right now
i know but we just showed them that we
were at chuck e cheese so now we're
going home did you have fun
what was your fun what was the funnest
thing you did
you picked that to play games yeah
oh you big cutie i'm happy what is it
oh
monkey i love you oh
monkey okay sorry all right eardrums um
thank you
thank you for spending such a cuny day
with us uh i hadn't been to chuck e
cheese in ages so it's really cool to be
back
and they have like this really cool
system now where you can either buy
points or you can pay for the for the
amount of time that you're gonna be
there so we bought like an hour's worth
and it was 20 bucks and it's like
unlimited play so that was really cool
to me to keep in mind for families and
the one out here i guess is what is this
summerlin
i think it's a summerlin one
yeah the one in summerlin is really cool
um i just recall all of the chucky
cheeses i went to when i was growing up
were pretty
yucky but this one's really cool so fyi
thank you guys so much for watching and
we'll see you tomorrow